que c'est bien un plateau il ya des
clashs airs hier soir encore boubacar
que sur ce plateau il ya eu du clash et
du et du bon clash même même mois et
même vous mêmes tout le monde d'ailleurs
il sera là dans ces clashs et on a fait
un petit un petit magnéto qui est ma foi
très intéressant
[Applaudissements]
mais je trouve que on a raconté mais des
inepties inepties sur l'ineptie dont
contre l' amalgame d'isabelle qui n'a
pas été compris entre benjamin castaldi
excuse moi qui relaie des fakes news de
la fachosphère en parlant d' apologie au
terrorisme ou en traitant des proxys en
prêtant si en prêtant une proximité
tu va retirer tout de suite en prêtant
aux 38 non je plaisante pas là entre et
auquel alors je plaisante pas tu aurais
fait pas tout de suite
malheureusement c'est les sources
benjamin mois intérêts de facho alors je
me cherche on n'arrive pas déconner la
liberté d'expression et en tant
qu'actrice conneries on est très
contents d'entendre vos conneries
quelquefois je pourrais dire le tribunal
de l'intelligence pourrait condamner de
leurs mots pour son dernier rôle jusque
chez nous
[Applaudissements]
deux ponts
sap est imposé en 44 84
et professeur de journalisme sous conte
[Applaudissements]
mais ce n'est pas dans nos manières là
je suis allé chercher dans sa douche sa
fille en prendre des photos
or ce fonds ou jalouse zeller notamment
regarder
combat et revient d'accord t'as pas à
garder occupés de moi atteint 7 8 ans à
tanger a marqué 12 fois champion du
monde mon poste rue de relayer des
rumeurs sur les réseaux son rôle est
rien du gouverneur
en tout cas merci à la ville d'avoir moi
je vais risquer ma vie dans 70 pays à
travers le monde
certains ne détournez vous nous donner
les journalistes et verdès vous donner
tous domanys absolument mais [ __ ] vous
stigmatisez études et magie mais
franchement ridicule et si vous êtes en
colère
l'habit et qu'est ce qui vous prend
d'aller provoquer un champion de boxe
mais imaginez que le mec il pète un
plomb il vous des montants 2000
surtout quand même en émane carte orange
wi voyez la sécu ou tous moi j'ai le
courage c'est d'assumer
oui d'accord c'est des conneries aussi
serré bref un peu entier comme ça mais
j'aimerais savoir si on est bon vu que
c'est cette émission était une grande
gueule est ce que dans la rue il ya des
gens qui se sont ouvertement manifesté
pour vous casser la gueule la question
est posée à les soucis que j'ai eu c'est
des gens qui tournent autour de fatou
j'ai eu ça plusieurs fois par an comme
un tout ça oui ça a dégénéré
quelquefois mais maintenant je prends
sur moi j'essaye de me contrôler je fais
un travail énorme à damas s'est très
vite et vous pensez vous fait peur quand
je crie un mois maintenant
[Rires]
tous ces gens dans man et ont raison
c'est que gilles verdez fait du
journalisme à 6 c'est-à-dire les
documentaires il l'est commente il est
assis la banque citibank il a si le foot
il commente il est assis à l'hymne de la
villardière et comment il est assis
temps mort pas eu ma poule tsi et ouvre
ta gueule
[Applaudissements]
je ne vois pas la tâche mais pas quand
même je suis témoin qu'à las vegas et
les faits se battre avec le directeur du
matin et il était debout
bon alors la lavette harangua capture
vous écoute toujours faillissent failli
quelque chose de la faille faire une
carrière un calme et vous quand même nom
mais n'est pas prouvée vite qu'il ait
fait des choses à six journées ce
basique et les rapports et parce que sa
longueur ok beaucoup beaucoup mais
critique des documentaires n'a jamais
fait un et critique la boxe et le sujet
là aucun parce que je trouve il à
jalouser besoin dans tous ses clashs
alors que lui ne fait pas grand chose en
face c'est ce que je dis donc je veux
redire je produis prenait parti pour
tous ces gens fils qui ont été classés
tous ces artistes comme moi qui ont été
clash est violemment les artistes des
gens qui critiquent vous bernard vous
étiez le statut d'autonomie est un
bagarreur vous non pas dans tous n'ont
jamais pour bien cela moyennant même
contrée de machines à uv qui était
robert moyen de d'esquiver vous savez la
violence s'est brisé c'est quoi c'est là
où courir ou vite appeler les gardes du
corps ça n'a jamais eu de problèmes mais
ça va au fond s'affrontent directement
c'est à dire qu'on y va et et là c'est
très con parce que tu prends un pète à
la gueule tu fais la télé depuis 35 ans
et là après été mobilisés pendant quinze
jours j'ai très peur de perdre mais dans
ouais c'est pas les vôtres et pas les
vôtres
si si au bout d'un mois mais l'autre ça
fait 40 ans qu'il eut bien de tout le
monde